three
three down
ah freedom is the show and that's
good where you go away and you
won't do your freedom home show my
name is lauren my name's scott my
name's paul and we're three of them
and we're here to tell you
stories about our lives where people stop
being polite and start getting real that's
right we're called real dumb and this
is where everyone stops being nice to
each other and they start saying rude
this is basketball wives and we play
basketball and then we marry each other
yes queen yes
tomorrow went hold on i need the
smelling salts for lauren has ooooo wake
up where am i have you ever
smelled smelling salts yeah no i told
you in my recent recent ish operation
they had to get them out for
me that's right you wouldn't wake up
need because they feared i was about
to faint you hit the snooze alarm
on your operation
what happened ah yes or no you
know i sit on a seat i
talked about it in in a previous
episode so go back and listen with
you'll enjoy it yes with you i
think and you didn't care then oh
my god i care now is what
i'm trying to tell you well i
see i'm telling the story no i
think it's alright day i've told you
have to give her time to care
because she was going to take care
of them and all prior now maybe
i cared then i just don't remember
yeah that's okay i don't remember every
detail of your life i remember carrying
you marry doing exactly yeah wait smelling
salts something else shit was cool up
overheard it and it was like you
gotta get the smelling salts
she screamed she said that no she
heard them she heard them seeing the
same feeling rushing from the other room
where she was having her own procedure
they call them smelling salts and just
making me wonder if i would have
smelling salts something science-y science showing get
the science smell to hide
or something would put me out i
think hello get all my pre its
fake mother died malda hide yeah he's
call it multi-hit call it tama hide
he needs the bizarre rack get some
a high kill wake up then give
daschle a tiff rim um yeah because
smelling salts reminds me of like downton
abbey shit you know what i mean
yeah old timey may have to revive
it
smearing shows but then they snap at
the like snap it open and then
then i remember being like okay a
lot is like able nitrate oh i
think they'd like snap it open like
it's it releases it and then releases
the smell and then i was like
yeah i was like yeah yeah okay
okay okay get that a wave get
it away from me but that's
that's what what's things right yeah it
stinks it's smell so does it stink
like i can they make it smell
nice i know i know have it
there oh look i'm getting i'm getting
cotton candy but i am geddy lee
oh hi welcome yeah from rush cotton
candy jelly bellies are some of the
best there are is that trista ever
do
it what about cotton candy grapes i
don't like those i've never had the
uncanny they're really shocking to me cotton
candy grapes do you think that they
should give them to raccoons to make
up for when the raccoon tried to
wash the cotton candy that disappeared i
do think i've never seen constant funny
you've ever seen it's really funny
it sounds like an instinct classic because
the raccoons they have to wash the
little foods before they eat them why
because they're civilized dear darling those little
hands if it has hands you'd like
to wash its food and so this
guy's washed his hands can you wash
the greg
what's that from
meet the parents darryl yeah it was
recently watched easily
i watched it with the last six
months but it was really fun to
go we um ah he they give
us raccoon some cotton candy he goes
to watch it of course not its
ups and he's so fucking confused oh
yeah what i got is yeah that's
sad too my wash it away i
wonder if every food should
dissolve i wonder sometimes sure that's true
well he said although you have acid
in your body you don't like it
i don't think about like what if
it gets out stomach acid well that's
when you go ah barfi and it's
gross yeah what's the first thing you
remember borrowing
no like where you're like that's not
vomit that's something i a recent roll
of pennies recently no no i just
mean the recently peaceably s
the i just it was always birth
to me until one day it's just
barked to me it was always part
she was always just until one day
because you're eric barf yeah store saw
ranbir and then they were like oh
that and that's from one eight that's
that peas and carrot soup know i
remember i remember getting really sick and
coming back to school and talking about
the school nurses going like i need
to
go home i feel sick i'm embarking
on our front porch and it being
the orange cinnamon rolls that i'd had
that morning orange cinema i think you
should apart from all the sounds toxic
those are good really
a what what do you mean orange
cinnamon roll you know like the the
orange they have orange frosting instead of
the i do not know oh they're
in their seventy's household classic does it
taste like ah like a previously rapped
yeah yeah tuna can you previously own
oh it's by chan it's like it's
like pillsbury dough
so it's like pillsbury so then you
make them and then you they all
you put them in the oven and
then they they give you the the
end of the the roll is this
orange frosting just like pillsbury yeah you
put the orange on them and they're
delicious oh yum when we see a
big fat baby yeah i love when
janey says punch her in the arm
life
maybe you see was a slug about
pantoja we put in the car for
the car we submit fat babies ah
one jay this always makes me delight
in virginia will say like his arms
look like grands like pillsbury grand oh
yeah i want a fat baby has
just like all those roles it's so
good yeah so
q it's so good that when you
have the you almost always the wrist
roll well you're the big guy never
slid yeah you wish they never grew
up and just kept the are you
issued they got bigger but then have
the baby body i wish doesn't seem
like something a baby yeah wow i
wish everyone was very good maybe there's
some picturing it and it's
really scary because the baby doesn't fin
out i'd like it but it's like
remained same my body would fit ah
but your body may be it in
with other baby bodies yeah
i get it well hey i've gone
hey get the smell results are lower
and i'm awake and i'm good i'm
just my eyes are closing good and
volume like i'm well i'm glad my
isaac and i'm drifting off manners shows
up it's just my eyes are tired
oh your poor darn i'll never believe
that
lauren if you fell asleep in the
middle of the show it would feel
so good i would love to fall
asleep right now i really would i'm
tired well how like the list when
did you wake up i woke up
at six thirty when did we get
your wordle seven seventy five i don't
keep tabs on
by the way there are probably four
people in our texts never done a
word who must i think of them
now every single time we do in
like waking up going fucking lie getting
the like the muted us you know
what sucks about meeting on your phone
you can mute the do not disturb
on that that thread however it still
tells you you have a mistake and
they seem as well i don't think
you should
sigh oh i don't think shitty i
hope that they get them and go
god bless these guys are still doing
it i love that they go while
they're all live you know yeah in
a way we don't know if these
people are alive is proof of lying
but i do feel like we should
probably stop it soon you're the one
who started it i know they i
remember but here's what i'm thinking because
john was started by saying let's i'll
do this and compete with each other
yeah yeah and and in a way
it was great to keep elegant fun
for a while and there's still like
it i still why don't i enjoy
just like it but here's what i
would think but tall john said when
he got he didn't get it right
he got x out of six he
said he was gonna quit buster and
then he didn't quit let's write because
we reward him i think
whoever every time one of us get
doesn't get it you have to stop
sending beauty playing we just kept sending
it and then eventually it'll well it'll
go down yeah you liked everyone sends
it yeah i do i don't dislike
that everyone sends it i'm just i'm
ready for it to wind down yeah
if it stopped for life to wind
down soon
okay that's upsetting judy's well with another
thirty years or so
i was like oh we want like
a thirty year wind down yeah just
why just slapped wonder how do you
feel about aging like how long would
you like to live do you feel
like there's a cutoff where it's like
well i don't want to live that
long just talking to my mom about
this the other day and she said
that sometimes talking your mom to oh
shit she said someone at our church
said ab
after eighty it's just basically game over
like it's all down and i don't
believe that i don't believe that enough
for everyone exactly the same frame i
mean look at william shatner who
space the final okay
like there's a lot of people who
have a lot of energy passed up
yeah like like ah he was doing
shit your dad says at like eighty
two or something like that you know
and he's still kicking around ninety or
whatever it's like i'm sure it's fine
for some people but i think people
have also of my parents' generation you
know i think i told you that
my
dad had an over the hill party
at forty yeah where it was like
here's here's you know your cane old
man yeah stuff like that so she
truly was like a lot of people
that they knew you know died at
forty five or fifty really yeah so
yeah so anyway i remember like having
a heart attack at fifty seemed like
a
i'm and say i was like yeah
unlikely quebec it was the thing that
was going to happen but look here's
the other thing i've been watching a
lot of old movies recently everyone smokes
and then oh yeah and so it's
like a yeah the more you see
that the more you go like oh
of course everyone was having yes and
fifty they're all killing themselves and each
other yeah yeah yeah so um i
i feel like it is a quality
of life thing
um where if i'm if i'm still
look i want to live as long
as i can if i'm still doing
good san juan mean i wanna live
as long as i can yeah i
don't feel like it's it's wild to
me the idea although i know it
is for some people to get to
that point like my mother went into
hospice care before
she died that was her decision like
she went off of dialysis because of
other issues that she had and the
doctor's like if you keep doing this
your quality of life is going to
get worse and worse or you could
do this and let nature take its
course and she did it and like
and i may have i feel like
now i've talked about this on here
before murder mariah so but the idea
of being able to say like i've
lived enough life like that's i can
i can let go is like because
where i am in life right now
is like climbing like please let yeah
yeah live it seems like something that
i don't know that i'd be able
to exist like oh no this has
been good yeah ma yeah but then
i guess if you do live long
enough if you make it to your
age
s or whatever you will be a
better judge of what constitutes a life
lived yeah well as my father said
someone said to him like something like
oh it's seventy it's all kind of
over whatever and he's like yeah i'll
talk to you when you're seventy you
know yeah it's like it doesn't really
feel that way yeah everyone just wants
to smoke spots yeah
much younger inside yeah it's so true
what a cruel trick that fate plays
really is horrible i lately even think
about it a lot we're just see
someone walking in a struggle they're gonna
die
ah i'm not really happy about it
it's like my brain's been doing that
for me where i'm just going like
on that person has a whole life
and then that's gonna end or something
so i just say oh god it
is i'm just beginning to feel the
thing of
feeling younger inside than my body is
like the last time we did a
show and then there was a scene
where you died and you just collapsed
on the floor yeah and then i
then later there was a mirroring of
that where i should have collapsed on
the flower yeah new stuff like sat
down very yeah really
geez i don't but if there was
a time for sure i was like
yeah i'll just fall down no yeah
i mean i was thinking about that
with our tour that has ended by
the time we did this and who
knows how it went but ah everyone
broke their foot but the first time
the first one was ten years ago
and i like think about the energy
we had i can't believe it was
that long ago yeah i don't think
you were on the one
ten years ago ten years ago although
you did the philadelphia show oh yeah
that was tough
tom wells yeah twenty twelve wasn't who
is the main cast i think james
damian went on us the whole time
and i think well i know kurt
brown owner was yellow did the opening
set all the time and occasionally did
the show i did more than just
that one show because i remember we
were in san francisco
yeah with james yeah oh and you
know that was that was the birthday
boys when the birthday that was the
second or you were on the you
were on the whole second i was
on the whole after the first one
i think you were too busy to
do the second one when i was
in no oh no
second one was when i was in
er no no no i think you
were in the third third one yeah
yeah anyway it was a lot of
fun and but ah you know you
were back to martin short and steve
martin there they're up there and still
doing it but can they do it
every night in a row i don't
know yeah yeah yeah i think you'll
definitely be great i'm gonna be okay
i mean i'm na
not gonna do not seventy s exactly
i mean that's a whole different thing
i'm going to try to maintain a
very strict regimen of diet and no
alcohol all around the damn no alcohol
like zero lauren i know that's hard
for you to hear because you'd love
to party i'd go crazy for this
stuff but i do feel like at
the end of you know the middle
of the tour it's kinda nice to
get a drink everyone so all you
might you might go back on that
i might but like i don't want
the exact cure because i know i
know how much it can affect my
energy most of our food because you
feel like shit yeah it's
we're talking about this before we do
it and yet this week but i
know this will come out after it's
already done or disasters happened on it
yeah like we quit in the middle
of there can't be obi wan kenobi
become a huge star unless you both
get copied which i hope you don't
i don't want to get caught of
it i shout either of us will
but that's another thing is i know
it affects my energy lev
will yeah even if i have like
two glasses of wine yeah it'll be
like the next sale feel it yeah
i drive it i also don't want
to let my there's a lot of
driving they used you always drive because
you save for insurance right now i
just feel responsible for everybody i would
feel i don't know i just feel
like if there's gonna be a horrible
accident i should be
even a minor one you sue
i think that's that's nice i things
but i feel bad that you do
all the driving answer it's fine we'll
see how i feel without with this
thing on foot you might need someone
else to do yeah dang yeah but
hopefully this comes off tomorrow and guys
everything's all good but i mean even
still you don't want to overwork it
by you know getting a lot yeah
guess
yeah as bray oh darling why not
both
oh also my broke for gas i
heard it is
ah but i don't know it'll be
fine but yeah aging aging stuff if
you could stop aging at what age
would you like physically because some video
ho you know how when you look
at like you you feel old when
you're eighteen but then he looks so
young you look so young like but
what's the perfect age where you're like
that should be the cutoff
like well i don't think you know
until you've passed that exactly honestly if
i from this vantage point i would
say forty i think forty is a
great age yeah i think it's a
great one eight
twenty seven twenty five i'm now going
lower and lower twenty three do you
have any
three years old i'll go on a
steal i mean years old i feel
great even though this comes out so
much later who gives a shit it
doesn't matter fuck it's just past the
point as we explained why i'm not
in the tour oh why because i'm
doing a movie but i'm saying everyone
i feel like people are gonna she
had babies she's not gonna go do
anything anymore and i don't let's hope
my life is i just want to
say no you're
or lifestyle ah informs yeah yeah wow
saying i have a crazy life i'm
just saying i would like to go
on the tour yeah well you were
invited dear i know when i'm doing
a movie don't know she's gone i'm
explaining for them so that they don't
speculate yeah for the no speculation everything's
good everything's all good between it's literally
shooting august one to september once the
exact date so yeah what are you
doing for labor day
well it's my birthday weekend um gotta
wear white pants i'll be running fun
to write pants and going to funny
girl getting on me i'm i'm going
to be in chicago for my birthday
i'm staying a few extra days after
i'm done filming that's the dream hang
out with my family that's the dragon
chicago for your birthday to celebrate my
b-day may you all be in chicago
on your birthday yeah my fun
fondest wish for you all to be
chicago your birthday after you finish filled
it yeah it doesn't sound great i
can't wait till somebody at that point
they like that'll just feel great do
you think there'll be any wind up
you know what probably not it's usually
pretty hot time a year yeah are
you gonna do a cameo on the
bear season two if they ask me
how's your yelling i'm really good at
screaming about we have no one
north river north that's where they are
i really enjoyed that show cool upset
i really like but i've only watched
the first episode i haven't seen the
rest oops i'm sure much time i
will have watched it and i don't
know oh why should i just didn't
feel like i was i was two
drinks into the night i was like
i don't want to concentrate on this
sometimes you gotta just let it go
you know two drinks into the night
how many drinks you have a night
i was probably too but that makes
me sleepy yeah we may have talked
about this before but i'm never in
the mood to watch like a documentary
yeah but if if janie starts it
then you'll get really interested because they're
so compelling and you'll walk by and
go like what is this piece of
home
which is real oh may do it
but i will because i feel like
at the end of the day i
want to i don't want to i
don't want to ah concentrate on something
yeah they don't really mean i want
something that's easy to just like let
that happen that's what reality tv is
for it to me yeah you can
just be on your phone and trying
to picking up the beats of it
yeah welcome to plath
il is really taking off the season
well we started watching on the platform
and are you being paid by welcome
to plateau i bring it up i
feel like i've never talked no just
the way you keep w i bring
up a lot but it was the
platteville tower they like eating they they
it's like the bell jar and they
live in the novel the bell jar
no
oh and the butterfly where one person
can only communicate while backing that was
a good it's based on these two
parents who like i haven't had the
courage rabies yeah mimi oh no i
never could see that again it's so
great though it's so it was just
bawling i know but i ain't blinking
at my friend going do you see
i'm sad wait bowling going out i'm
sad i was just hey
people misspell bawling and no bawling my
eyes out i'm like really super it's
really what are you you're fucking your
own eyes oh no see i thought
it was like bawling my eyes out
was like a cantaloupe baller yeah melon
baller we have to take a break
okay boof
ah doing it we're doing it we're
doing it well will you wear a
rubber are you my lover
it's been it's lyric from doing it
well will you wear a robber are
you my lover do you remember she
earns more than thirty rappers remember that
book with a little duck walked around
asking are you my lover are you
my lover are you my love i'm
gonna do with you know where robert
lilly people he's wearing this robber i'm
like damn
but i like to move it move
it
alright let's go let's go to hell
hell with all of us no let's
go to ah one of these ah
isn't you know one of these ah
the fuck is wrong okay tryna to
say one of these voicemails someone please
please scott okay yeah here we go
yeah i don't know who this is
oh call a moron um i am
a longtime listener and i am twenty
two years old and putting two thousand
twenty two years just recently graduated university
and i was wondering if you guys
have any advice on how to make
when past due
recipe into your adult life where should
i be going who should i be
talking to do you have any tips
i would greatly appreciate some hope you'll
have all have a greece's device
well nameless person mostly my tips next
time introduce yourself yeah you're trying to
help yeah number one it's hard with
an axe but i don't know what
your name is most of my advices
retroactive drop out of college ah get
into show business yeah you've got to
do improv desperately tried to fit in
and be afraid that they're gonna think
you're not cool
so here's the problem most people's jobs
their work friends are just so uncool
yeah is that true probably like any
job by guys you're just like oh
and why that retail jobs where i
liked a lot of the people children
maybe a little different because you're all
about the same retails pretty cool i
don't like my waiting table jobs unless
it was in the middle
out of nowhere it was a bunch
of old ladies in may most of
the time is like young kids that
you would maybe hang out with but
but like if you're working in an
office job everyone around you sucks right
so you gotta you gotta figure out
ways to get out there and meet
people in other areas but i think
the internet has made this so much
easier that there are now like get
together kind of things
is that you can go well there
is an app to make friends yeah
so when i oh it's like you're
saying it's like tinder for friends or
something i think that it was like
i heard about that i thought that
was the sweetest nicest thing um are
generally swim lay around and be like
no thank these churches yeah i think
i think that would i would not
put passing them i don't know
add up your mind mister option using
one of those apps because you can
make a friend and mechanical and then
i feel like it's tough because it's
like if you have one friend maybe
it's like if you have one friend
you asked them to bring another friend
when you hang out or some yeah
yeah hey time and row the group
anxiety yay yeah all thirty yeah also
by the way you
you can as a woman you can
go to a bar you're speaking as
shows so what are you gonna tell
me i can do you can go
to a bar and meet a million
people that is not true yeah go
to a bar so you to belong
to everyone will start talking no yeah
no one wants to
read ma'am i think you would maybe
sign up for an activity like trivia
night or something like that or like
but it's hard to cool alone to
things like i think you'll like what
do you like like knitting or something
like with something that's kind of a
solo activity that you could take a
class and meet people yeah there's i
feel like what's good about one of
the things that is
is good about the internet is that
it's easier to connect with people now
than it ever has been you can
find those sorts of places to go
where there's going to be groups of
like-minded people that you can at least
you will have a a jumping off
point for a conversation like it's like
you all like the same tv show
or you all like you know some
kind of game or something i once
went to a band
alone and meet a concert a concert
yeah and i started talking to someone
because i thought i recognize them and
realized quickly that it wasn't the person
i thought of but we struck up
a conversation it's it's that easy i
just think it's funny because we both
have the interest of this band yeah
yeah
yeah i mean you know it's it's
a really hard thing though because i
think so many of my friendships were
just made from doing improperly and i
know just naturally met people and yeah
but i've i was very lucky to
have that because i always think when
i moved to new york i moved
to la and i had that as
like a thing i was doing but
a number of class if you don't
think that sucks you might not if
you listen to this you might think
perhaps fun you could take an improv
class
i've never been upset at someone who
just starts a conversation though well i
mean they're well that's true but yeah
those you know any normal who just
someone i don't know who's just like
you chatting yeah chatting with another alone
person i also think the other thing
is you have to say yes to
a lot of opportunities like if you
get invited to a party you have
to go even if you don't like
the move last man yeah you know
because i would just
not want to do that random movie
yes man just watch that do what's
like hanging out with friends yeah jim
carrey different guys struck up a conversation
with me on an airplane which normally
i would hate but and i do
not like it we started talking to
me yeah and then we had a
great conversation and then did you keep
in touch i he gave me his
car because i said hey i'm i'm
i was coming back from portland and
and i said i'm doing a show
in what's that bridgetown know his average
down oh where's that it was well
portland is bridge that's what i mean
but i was doing a show with
mark jackson and then when i was
flying back this guy we started talking
and i was like hey i'm coming
back here um with comey bang bang
going to do a show
ah give me your email and i'll
let you know when we're going to
be there and i'll put journalist and
i can do that yeah well i
still have the card yeah also have
a baby and bring it to a
park or a dog have a dog
baby well it's interesting i think get
on the news that baby has a
baby riding a dog a wide yard
or p
people constantly coming up to you and
talk no not at all i'm no
no one's doing that um i also
think covert plays a role with that
too but like guy thing covert plays
around sneezing and having people spaces now
maybe this for you a person who's
listening i don't know anything about you
maybe you have a pet maybe i
would dumb but like getting together with
someone who also has a baby is
a thing where it's like you kind
of
make friends like i'm making friends solely
based on that i mean yeah and
it's like that's not something i do
in my life like seek out new
people to hang out with and like
make a plan and go to it's
like that's usually a lot of effort
for me i was just i like
to just hang out usually it seems
like all the friends that i made
in my life where like okay i
graduate college and then i was
they were all work friends until i
started doing comedy and then they became
all comedy friends right so it's like
if if the people at your job
end up sucking which they probably will
but maybe they won't you know maybe
they won't maybe maybe this person is
gonna work somewhere like relatively cool or
something like yeah i'm like happy whole
really tesla like something like that like
be friends with you on mosque where
are you
you might meet someone who's like minded
because you're both interested in the job
and then you can hang out in
goods yeah but then you have to
ask people to hang out and that
sucks and it's hard but you do
it it's true like getting that's why
i think if you can if you
can get yourself into a situation where
there is something that you all have
in common that draws you there whether
it's a trivia night or whatever
are themed around something than at least
you have an icebreaker there's something you
could definitely use to start a com
if you have a job where there's
five people who would go to a
trivia game with you invite all of
them even if you don't like them
too will be like fuck this and
fuck you yeah and then you'll weed
them out
if anyone says fuck you i ain't
they're not negative perception people in offices
yeah because maybe they're cool did you
ever worked in an office yeah but
like working a warehouse of one where
the warehouse for example your office an
office and i've met met yeah and
they're all there yeah and they are
friends with each other but yeah maybe
the problem is you buck that
ah um but basing friends around your
common interests is really good because it
gives you something to talk about and
then whenever there's like a thing that
comes up you can go do togethers
where if if it's music it's like
hey these people are playing and you
go do it if it's films it's
like oh the this movie is playing
somewhere and you can go do that
if it yeah ah some sort
of athletic activity it's like hey on
this weekend if it even if it's
just hiking like hey do you want
to go on a hike this weekend
i need more exercise like it's that
easy to say that to someone that
you kind of enjoy now did i
ask someone if they wanted to go
hang out with me once that that
was i thought was a work friend
that could transition into real friend yeah
any show
me down immediately wow what did he
say we're work friends like he was
just like nah i don't think so
wow pretty honest and and you know
what phase that person out of my
life because i don't need that kind
of shit it sounds like they faced
you immediately they were now friends when
our friends like that when i get
some time know i'm gonna phase you
out
i'm gonna slowly sure that we don't
ever hang out you won't even realize
it's happening
and that was matthew mcconaughey alright do
we want to hear another one i
do alright
here we go anyway oh hey don
my jordan was listener um i just
wanted to know what each of your
first concerts were that you might do
and how that affected your ongoing concord
experiences i always think it's interesting ah
learning what people first concerts are oh
do yeah ah a bike
was that amber jordan amber
aberlour jordan to the phone
what about that fucking loud ass elderly
sophie alert yeah ruler jesus christ it's
so sad just text me i don't
know i think blaring noise x three
you didn't get it i don't know
if i have turned or had turned
off what was your first concert lauren
it's i don't i don't want to
offend the band but i don't stand
by oh yeah
yeah um dispatch remember that band yeah
it was kind of enroll yes one
eight hundred general now was they sing
yeah ah then they used it for
the commercial but i my friend was
really into it hence we went i
didn't know the songs as well as
other people did which is why if
it gets a tough first one because
it wasn't fully
yeah but it was was it fun
to go and i had a lot
of fun and i bought a shirt
and i wore the shirt all the
time and were you like oh they
were good of course we had a
great time and um i in high
school went to a lot of concerts
as like once that once that broke
the seal of that i had a
lot of fun doing got a badass
a little doing that mine was
a lot of fun it's emotion in
my teenage years going to these musical
experience i did i did use to
enjoy such things my first concert was
squeeze pulling meth and i'm go wow
yeah that's good that's great who does
who is support i dorner who support
was um but it was really ah
ah it was really fun and like
i support that when you call an
opening beyond i've never heard it called
support it's an english yeah oh who
compared that show um but it was
it was great it was um the
way i want to say like the
hourglass eric glass that was your first
really that was nineteen hundred and eighty
eight
yeah yeah yeah so you you i
don't think i'd been to a concert
before that no interesting you were like
twenty or so i would have been
coming up on twenty yeah yeah yeah
wow yeah and i don't see this
i don't really like to go to
big concerts i don't like to stand
i'm a sit down guy yeah and
when it's packed i think that time
has passed for me for sure yeah
yeah yeah but i never liked it
i never really went to i did
a certain point we went to lizzie
maybe three years or so ago back
when people were still doing stuff and
it was at the palladium and it
was one of those things where it's
like you need to stake out your
territory and it's gonna be so packed
that essentially you're just gonna be like
rocking back and forth on your feet
all night and shit tears me up
socks nowadays i would much rather just
be in the wei wei bao yeah
hold over when we went to see
prints that time yeah like way up
in the nosebleeds and it was fucking
great yeah and like i he was
very far away yeah he's tiny and
sw
so there's a screen there but still
you just watched yeah as far away
as he was you could not you
could not take your eyes off that's
cool yeah it was great but i
yeah i remember having a lot of
fun teaching that was a fun one
which one strokes that was very fun
i remember cause it's going to see
the pogues um live which abandoned i
love
strobes
that's different voter groups go
just go oh it's not in the
style of the oh yeah and vice
versa then they switched oh yeah but
american buffalo no true es to um
although they did it with american buffalo
recently i feel like where everyone played
the parts or something really i feel
i mean this old player you're just
reading him yeah hey
um moment yes
um but i did not realize that
people marched so i got there early
i got like upfront oh wow when
the opening band started and i like
made my way and i was like
yes it was like kind of easy
to get up here oh no no
and then when they came out they
everyone started going fucking crazy and i
was like ooh yummy
daddy i don't like it i used
to go to christian concerts which i
don't really count now because those were
the only ones i was allowed to
but i started like steve taylor i
talked about among yeah so to good
episode of good christian but ah but
my first real official concert i count
is only go boingo and nineteen eighty
five f pacific
amp theater it's might be on youtube
it was a good concert halloween night
nih funding they do on halloween it
was really true ah man and my
friend and i love mango bango and
we watched um did they play the
penguins ballad or whatever from bettman to
yeah
yeah which is weird because it hadn't
come out for another four years ie
maybe be fun to write music like
that wouldn't it would but let's do
it
e her um and of course i
famously saw billy vera and the beaters
when oh yeah eighty four that's right
out here right at a little knocked
club yeah what is it still there
i don't remember the i wish i
remembered the name of the club i
wonder if my sister remembers was i
wonder if it's placed already too since
on the strip
guess op does she still live on
the west coast she lives in germany
the co yeah it's high here i
mean she lives in moonshine that's oh
you're not yet dude why we went
before the pandemic it was really cool
i loved it i was like yeah
i would really like to get data
that was the most beautiful places ever
seen you know or germany germany and
gen
arrl i was like are you high
right now was he yeah yeah oh
um dirty i mean every time he
sees in movies fucking ripped i mean
i am every time you see in
a movie it's black-and-white there's like wire
everywhere people are shooting at each other
what movies are you watching
bridge of spies for two movies
ah
eric horvitz oh yeah whoa how mad
must you have been when if you
are gorbachov because you can't go on
accusing holds out no i lie whoa
i was going to do it anyway
fucking asshole i'm not doing good you
said so i'm doing because i want
to do it because what it was
like three days later he did it
i can't remember what was the timeline
that clothes feels like it it feels
like he just got he's doing it
for clout like megan was like it
was i knew he was gonna do
it yeah exactly he got intel like
hey they're tearing down the wall that's
three days that is a baller move
i got to say
ah well mr gorbachev oh here's what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna go in
there and i gotta say it's my
idea
go read more almost there come on
learn you might take one more call
yeah don't say come on i'm doing
great i just didn't know about all
lauren hi dr lin chor makoto philadelphia
ormoc um that's why first i have
a question for you
what did you call your grandparents
for example i called my grandparents i
got on my dad's side i have
my mom and poppy metering other side
my mom's side i have my mom
and papa
tu mama what did you call your
grandparents you was weird i don't want
to answer this
why you feels you're perfect yeah well
mine are all dead i've no problem
it feels personal to me i don't
okay you don't have to or anything
you have to but what did you
yeah ours were very simple it was
grant my mother's side was grandma and
grandpa and my father's i was granny
and grandad
huh both my grandfathers died before i
was born i remember wow mine were
super simple as grandma grandpa on both
ends but
that then i have these relatives that
i because of what we called them
one was nana one was tanti tanti
why that these were titles i came
to find out of like like you
know my mom or papa or whatever
and these were titles but i but
they were never explained to me of
what the relationship
it was to me until later so
one was a great aunt oh and
one was a great grandmother i believe
and it was i think that was
nana and tanti was my great aunt
and it was just like very like
okay if it feels like a nickname
in a way yeah yeah you know
um so yeah those were
but but but that was never explained
to me so until i was like
twelve it was like oh she's my
great aunt oh okay the truth from
you yeah they hid everything from me
parents lie and lauren i'm sorry but
you're gonna end up lying too but
who already am who you say the
side
ooh is like a baby all the
time who is to decide what they're
going to be called well just narrowly
side i mean my family now that
my grandparent you know the grandparents of
my child have decided that what they
want to be called yes but i
don't know if that was how that
always went like i don't know i
mean i think that's more current yeah
i think it is and i think
that it also you can decide what
you want to be called but then
ultimately it's kind of up to the
baby what the baby ends up being
able to pronounce right well that's true
like like some of the names that
we use now are based on my
nephew could say exactly yeah my sister
the aforementioned ah citizen of german
person um she could not say ah
aunt rosalie is my aunt who lived
next door and so she was always
re-roll we called a re-roll for fun
row and i didn't realize that's like
one of the things you grow up
with and then eventually it is explained
to you like right why didn't god
hey yeah that's not her name
her name they call me re row
alright we have to take break we'll
be right back
welcome back to the huh oh welcome
back
welcome back to the show oh i
love your natural what does my
i don't think you would ever work
if your voices like that ever
or maybe you would work more who
knows you know when i think about
vin diesel playing groot yeah it bothers
me sometimes yeah because it's just a
simple line yeah and it could be
anyone into someone should have well it
was wrong getting a lot of money
it was well paul the guardians of
the galaxy were not considered to be
popular characters so it was like telling
people like oh
oh here's another interesting fact about them
and the cumulatively the effect was oh
okay i'll go see that movie and
then people enjoyed it i think they
had enough i think they had enough
with ah yes bradley cooper exactly what
about him he did well he had
to do more acting so i get
like okay that's why you guys character
was really
the involved he had pain and suffering
but if you watch the videos vin
diesel's doing the most chimay groot happen
he wears stilts in the recording that
was so fucking stupid
i could not believe that when i
saw unnecessary yeah and then he did
it in every language yeah i like
that no you know you're there's more
people you're taking work right pose soy
group yeah because the amount of money
that would be made from each one
of those boring group and if you
spread that around to twenty other people
who could do those
nice
my name is groot i think it's
nice but i think it's nice when
the actor who does it who do
i made my last person because effort
to do because other leg when i
was a kid and you'd get like
a toy and you could tell it
was obviously not whoever did that is
true that is true but then if
the other languages are not being dubbed
by everyone else in the film then
it's kind of like who cares
like if you get a job i'll
never let go of my baby find
a job take it like you pull
a string and then make some money
hey youngest guy walker hey skywalker hey
are you my son
very different take on dorothy space villain
that's what the name of the box
said alright are we ready yeah we're
about to do three-tier yeah it's three
your time yeah and if you're not
ready for this i advise you to
sit down shut your trap it open
your ears as wide as you can
call your relatives tell them that
that look you might not be coming
home ever because this is gonna blow
your fucking mind i know you're not
sitting down at home sit down wherever
you are yeah sit down if you're
in the middle of the subway sit
down yeah a dream last night i
was on about to have huh i
dreamed i met a calumny
looks amazing man this is a data
fe site and what a bearded will
these that i'm finished paul what a
bearded his name was jesus paulo fish
don't interrupt
aw oh la la la la la
what's the game we play a three-acre
i wait for lauren to ask me
the musical question by the time we
do our last episode lawyers say their
arms folded that note hey donald it's
true i'm being very polite she has
her hands folded in her lap to
the point of like get this fuck
thing over with no it's true i've
been to offer polite to the point
of seething resentment just play the game
that does sound like you're having fun
this game was submitted by dominic dominic
ever read oh
but see you guys know things i
don't know you gotta watch the fast
furious movies simply got to i watched
two of them and now i know
they're gone and i don't care this
has been about dominic you know last
names just one i know i watched
the ninth one because i did isaac
guest on my own podcast
this game called skid five seconds ester
podcast they sell
this game is called skip five seconds
okay one person i'd like to skip
twenty minutes let's call them monica okay
goodbye everybody
one person let's say they're the mater
proposed proposes say you're the moderator okay
let's say they propose a topic for
debate the other to improvise a debate
and in anytime the moderator can say
five secs later and the debate looking
are you listening yes
because now it started at the beginning
no smell
skip five seconds one person
oh hey let's call him eight it
proposes a topic for debate call them
the moderator the other two gotta go
back to the beginning oh skip five
seconds submitted by dominic one person let's
call them the moderator proposes a topic
for debate the other to improvise debate
and anytime the moderator can say five
seconds later and the debaters jumped five
seconds into the future
or making references to whatever was said
during those missing seconds after three time
skips the debaters must bring the topic
to a conclusion now five seconds doesn't
sound like a lot but let's count
it out right now vive oh okay
alright fi why threaten joe
three ah
fireeye nine so c c yeah alright
yeah it's quite a lot of times
it's quite it's quite cool
wow such thing
good luck please
look no actually quite like we said
most high episode about ah cool cool
cool not gonna happen in five seconds
yeah how how much how much time
did it take for them to stop
seizure to death probably five seconds oh
and to add too fat to batter
two at two three
five two four three through tattoo bruce
j alright so i'll tell i'll be
the moderator
yeah sean taylor
oh boo tay oh we tay okay
so i'll be the moderator okay and
the topic that you shall debate is
i'm gonna be pro whatever it is
you're going to be con with sure
me yeah okay global warming global warming
debate starts now look the
the world's temperature changes that's just what
it is like for instance during the
winter hey hold on i'm going to
make it a dumb topic why yeah
yeah let's make a fun idea ah
you're a ni ah
i was just really bad i was
just a bonus for me yeah um
the topic is are there too many
koalas in the city centre alright i'm
pro this i'm con there are too
many yeah you don't want you think
there there are too many you think
there i think there's a great enough
yeah alright and your debate begins now
alright so i went down to the
city center the other day and you
know what everywhere i looked there was
a koala and i was like this
is so cute i showed them to
my kids i showed them to my
grandparents and nothing in between and i
thought that you know there's a perfect
amount of quality here right now because
if there were less koalas and that's
your time mister mom is like completely
i disagree obviously not only because i
was told to but because actually i
think there are too many koalas in
the city centre i cannot go shopping
without one of them crawling into my
shopping bag and biting my hand giving
me clomid i will not live this
way i don't want anyone to be
at risk they spread illness and they
and
that's why
yeah well look don't i didn't like
part of it i didn't refer to
i didn't well photographer okay i didn't
like wow he was i didn't like
when you just talked about how you
loved having chlamydia because it made sure
that no men would have sex with
you right because i didn't love that
i didn't love that counterpart i did
well i didn't five seconds later i
may not believe you just called me
that i literally someone arrested like you
i'll just say that anymore he's allowed
to say that oh my god faithful
today oh wow i can yell fire
in a crowded theater if i wanted
to die she wouldn't so amendment fire
no one believes you obviously know everyone
plays to fire
yeah no one should be getting up
because yeah okay anyway i thought it
was really strange that you just kissed
me right then you have chlamydia i
don't want it like it's just it's
it's unprofessional first of all during a
debate we're supposed to be on opposite
sides i was trying to prove a
point regarding the ways in
which i am a great kisser now
let me count the ways okay used
way too much tongue
you had the moderator five seconds later
okay now you have to route your
closing arguments please
ah long story short i feel like
it's very clear that we don't want
to koalas in the city center there
causing much havoc and they're completely unruly
and they should be in conservatories short
story long i think koalas are rad
i think the more that we see
them there's they're cute i think that
we can eat them if there ever
becomes too many
the problem refer to things that happen
i know i didn't think i'd think
you just said it's time for things
yeah he did but it's still the
the anytime that's five seconds later i
gave up booth yeah okay this one
sucks anyway
i think it can be good that's
oh
oh if you were to do it
it could be good yes you'd be
the moderator scott oh hey well topic
the topic is
are plastic bags too dangerous to be
floating around on this
on the surface of the ocean fun
look we all know what's going on
out there the plastic bags are covering
the entire surface of ocean allowing zero
sunlight to go down and animals are
eating plastic and rotting from the inside
out their insights are lined with target
bags how could you possibly think that's
a good thing see i knew you
were going to say that and what
i think is wonderful about this
is it's keeping down the population of
these live seconds letters
the lincoln assassination is a direct result
of these creatures and anyone whose patriotic
what's your time sir now to
two do you know my name is
brenda upside i just shit my name
have a brainwave admit i am having
a check on my podium whatever um
doesn't matter i just know you are
looking for my name and you couldn't
figure it out you were like and
back to dutta dot she'll just you
can talk this is not this is
counting i don't care
it's not running against my know sorry
so so we're trying to run out
the clock it's not working i'm starting
right yeah and i don't care when
you started it because now i'm starting
right now doesn't matter when you started
at a debate because this doesn't matter
now i'm stuck and it doesn't matter
if it was then now okay then
well yeah yeah again and i'm now
in plastic bags five seconds later
if you look into the eyes of
any child over the age of ten
you will see the remnants of the
ancient stingray that once enveloped the world
and now when you look into their
eyes you see the remnants of plastic
bags being made that they're being carried
home from the hospital because we have
so many yeah that's better i'm saying
is actually no
it's actually very dark and very bad
because what's going to happen now what
you're gonna see is that we're going
to have a world enveloped by ballistic
and that everything is going to be
covered in plastic and we're going to
have a horrendous why did you bring
a bed out on stage why did
you are you talking to me no
brenda oh i'm saying yeah you're brendan
everything's gonna be sorry why or why
you're curling up the plastic is up
with it
a day and is our god and
to have it do without it
twenty five seconds later and that's what
i mean because you know when you
see that go down you understand the
point you see right yeah out hell
time thank you for waking her upbringing
i want to thank everyone who helped
resuscitate me um i don't know what
happened that's never happened to me during
a debate before and um yeah why
were you talking to
during it i'm sorry that everyone had
to see that especially the inside part
of me um it's unprofessional and i
apologize right time and now for your
apology brenda i'm really sorry to everyone
out there who i'm with my language
and actions this is about stuff from
the past
i just want to use this platform
to kind of say i did some
stuff that wasn't great and hey me
hit like that several misinterpreted me i
mean like thirty more seconds that i
get to keep talking yeah great i
miss my family i do and if
you're out there watching this i rejoice
credit all i regret throwing out all
my kids toys to teach him a
lesson i will go turn on my
husband's clothes as each himalayas and i
regrets taking the gas out of the
car and siphoning it into a little
bucket twenty more seconds just to create
a sort of kabuto like flavor that
i was creating the to solely poison
my husband i mean
that hold on oh did you just
admit to poisoning your husband because i
too well he died we have noticed
that how did he die oh chose
chose
took it on a toad
and closing arguments and that's why that
is how it is and again folks
ah the time machine i cannot it
was for demonstration purposes only i cannot
take you back to see your dead
grandparents that would be in violation of
time law and i don't want to
be in trouble with the time cops
i rest my kick i give it
to him you're just you're forfeit you're
conceding as you say i succeed use
your seceding from the united states i
see i see i see
so you're a nation under yourself i
am once your money going to be
called the planes doublings doubling doubling doublings
and said doubloons and what's your what's
your country called number one city number
one city is your god damn it's
good god damn it is
really chilling schmuck i would figured of
seceding and and that's how you play
that yeah hey we did it we
did for this show if you say
so
it's a feature right to what's at
three-mile at three three mm usa gmail
dot com three man why didn't we
get three e-mails a mad it did
fuck no somebody else okay
they did fuck up so righteous had
three musa gmail dot com were freedom
usa on twitter and instagram ah and
our phone number if you'd like to
call us is haha lion poo you
figure it out you figure out what
they do write up we figure it
out with a pencil and a pad
you figure it out scott would only
give high
dance every day well okay here's the
deal i'm gonna be straight with you
thanks man gonna cut through all the
bees oh my god she's sure various
yeah he turned his hat forwards
he turned his frown upside down
shoes are on the opposite feet
in this case it's absolutely insane
bullock look you don't want to love
these ads that we have all over
the place like blah blah blah blah
i liked it there's too many ads
at the show right yeah every three
seconds it's like an ad for this
ad for that i know use your
thumb broken from hitting the thirty four
were into man to do these heads
and we get
it so we have a solution for
you if you want to hear ad-free
episodes of the show go over to
stitcher premium or or you can go
to cbp world and there's the ad-free
verses that way like you don't hear
us talking about mattresses or whatever the
fuck we're talking about you can just
hear us talking about this shit yeah
and that's so much better because you
don't have
fast forward and isn't that nice and
don't you deserve it you deserve aren't
you a nice boy okay and aren't
you daddy's brave boy because you took
your you took your booster shot and
you didn't even cry ah now here's
a little ice cream as a treat
for you and you know it before
you can have a chance
treat ah just a little salami huh
ah anyway huh we have two more
episodes before our season's done and believe
me the next two you're not gonna
want to miss it oh my god
we're gonna we're gonna tie everything together
it seems like it's gonna be like
endgame game we're gonna make it make
sense all of it like we should
do some coming attract
tions for it coming up in the
last two episodes of threesome i didn't
see that stop saying i said that's
not what i said i don't wanna
be your friend anymore okay oh you're
really you're where you want to you
broke my thumb everybody needs to get
um get a pad and paper oh
look a whale take a chill pill
well i got the clue double rainbow
but leg the and the floor is
covered in dog hair for some reason
who ah
that's a clear that boy that's what
a lot to look forward to thanks
for editing that i can't yeah we
lived through that boy i know see
well you're not gonna want to miss
those episodes so come back for very
exciting final two episodes of the season
it's a two-part season finale that's right
maybe series finale who knows who knows
we
i don't know yet
umm probably find out yeah before we
do those okay well anyway goodbye and
good luck good luck and good night
and good morrow goodnight bye
short sleeping sleepy